-Former President Donald Trump,
the current frontrunner
for the Republican Party's
presidential nomination in 2024,
called for the Constitution
to be terminated
after expressing support for the
January 6th insurrectionists
and now, the Republican Party
has finally come out
in full force to condemn Trump
and oust him from the party
and --
Oh, sorry, what's that?
They haven't condemned him?
[ Laughter ]
Why not?
Oh, for all the usual reasons?
Well, that's fun.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well...
we've been
off since Thanksgiving
and a lot has happened,
but, by far,
the most important thing
that has happened is
that Wally's sponge
is back, baby!
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's right.
Thanks to a winter uptick
in COVID cases,
our crew is, once again, masked,
which means Wally needs
to reattach his face sponge,
which serves the purpose
of keeping his fingers moist
between cue cards,
[ Laughter ]
a job his tongue
can no longer do
because his tongue is
behind a mask.
Now, I actually learned
this exciting sponge news
thanks to a tweet
from an eagle-eyed viewer
[ Laughter ]
who saw the face sponge attached
during last Saturday's "SNL,"
a show Wally also works for.
"That eagle-eyed viewer?"
you may ask.
Wally!
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, just to be clear --
Wally tweeted a video
of himself
to me and Sal,
in the hopes that we would
put him in "A Closer Look,"
and the worst part is?
It [bleep] worked.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
But it didn't work all the way.
No...
it didn't work all the way.
Because Wally only
gets paid extra if he has a line
and we ain't giving him
a line today, baby!
-Actually, Seth, Seth!
-What?! What?! What?!
-Nothing. "Actually, Seth" is
just enough to get me paid.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You're my Grinch!
[ Laughter ]
Believe it or not,
there is other news.
For example,
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell --
or as I call him,
America's Wally --
[ Laughter ]
...announced that he is running
for chair
of the Republican
National Committee,
which, if he wins, would put him
in charge of the GOP.
-MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
says he plans to run to be
the chairman of the
Republican National Committee.
Lindell said he was,
"100% running,"
during an interview
with Trump ally Steve Bannon.
The post is currently held
by Ronna McDaniel.
-I am 100% running
for the RNC chairman
against Ronna McDaniel.
100%.
I'm all-in, Steve.
And one of the things said --
one of the big donors said
to me,
he said, "Mike," he said,
"Everybody wants you
to be head of the RNC.
Some of them just
don't know it yet."
-I mean, I'd say he dreamt
that conversation,
but that meant he fell asleep,
which, one,
he seems incapable of,
and two, is impossible
using a MyPillow.
[ Laughter ]
The only way Lindell
ever got a solid eight hours is
if he used a TheirPillow.
[ Laughter ]
When he says
one of the big donors,
is he referring to a Republican
donor or an organ donor?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Lindell ]
I got a third lung installed,
so I could scream even louder
without taking a breath
and the big lung donor told me
I should be in charge of the RNC
right before they
put him under.
I think they gave him
too much morphine, though,
because he never woke up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, if he does, indeed, run,
Lindell would obviously focus
on his deranged election
conspiracy theories.
For example,
he's still going around
claiming the midterms
were stolen from Republicans.
-These machines, when they knew
that they were going to vote
same-day,
we said,
right here on "FrankSpeech,"
everybody vote same-day
because it's harder
for them to cheat,
so, we could overrun
the algorithms.
Well, when you took
those machines down in --
down in Arizona, you say,
"Put the ballot in the box.
Put the ballot in the box."
[ Laughter ]
Those ballots got mixed in
with other ballots, too,
by the way.
They basically became
mail-in ballots, everybody.
[ Laughter ]
And you know what we do
with mail-in ballots?
[ Laughter ]
Pull names from the
[indistinct].
Joe Schmo, Johnny Bananas,
Sue Smith, whatever.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
We've had a good time
with Mike Lindell
over the years, but,
at some point,
it stops being funny,
so, let me say,
with all seriousness,
you leave Johnny Bananas
out of this!
[ Laughter and applause ]
You think he's had it easy,
going through life with the name
Johnny Bananas?
You think that's a fun trip
to the DMV?
[ Laughter ]
A good icebreaker
for a job interview?
[ Laughter ]
You know how many times
his friends
have set Johnny Bananas up
on blind dates,
only for him
to show up to the restaurant
and see, not a human woman
at his table,
but a monkey...
[ Laughter ]
...in lipstick and a dress?
A monkey who his friends
have taught to wave,
so everyone at the restaurant is
looking when the hostess says,
"Right this way, Mr. Bananas."
[ Laughter ]
Sue Smith, on the other hand,
she can [bleep] right off.
That's not a real name.
[ Laughter ]
Also, what is Lindell
miming here?
-You know what we do
with mail-in ballots?
[ Laughter ]
-It looks like
he's milking a giant cow?
[ Laughter ]
Either that, or he's climbing
a tree, like...
-Johnny Bananas.
[ Laughter ]
-It's obviously very unlikely
that Lindell wins,
but his bid for RNC chair comes
at a time
when Republicans are
figuring out what to do
with the MyPillow wing
of the Republican Party,
a wing that includes
their standard bearer
and current presidential
frontrunner Donald Trump.
Almost as if he was trying
to outdo Lindell,
Trump took to his social media
site True Social
over the weekend and called
for the Constitution
to be torn up,
so that he could immediately
be reinstated as president.
-Former President Donald Trump
wrote
on his social media platform
this weekend.
He says...
-First of all, I like that
he started with the question,
"do you throw the" results out,
"or do you have a NEW ELECTION,"
like those are the only
two choices.
[ Laughter ]
He's like a five-year-old
who tells his parents,
"Okay, guys,
should we have ice cream
for dinner or...
should we have cake?
I...
[ Laughter ]
I see arguments on both sides."
But I also appreciate
he left no room for ambiguity
by using the word termination.
I mean, that's pretty explicit.
Republicans can't say
he misspoke,
although, I'm sure the
Ted Cruzes the world will try.
[ As Cruz ]
The woke mob wants
to destroy Donald Trump
just because his autocorrect
changed...
...to...
[ Laughter ]
Also, I like when Trump tries
to use what he thinks sounds
like sophisticated
legal language
and, instead, just sounds
like an insane person.
He thinks if he uses big words,
like "termination of all rules,
regulations, and articles,"
everyone will think what
he's suggesting is legal.
He sounds like a college
sophomore in a Starbucks,
writing a screenplay
for a sci-fi movie.
[ Laughter ]
"Exterior space.
It's the year 3000.
Nuclear war with an army
of sentient voting machines
has resulted in the termination
of all rules, regulations,
and articles.
[ Laughter ]
The galaxy's only hope
for survival rests
with a heroic astronaut,
Captain...
-Johnny Bananas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's two.
[ Cheering ]
That's two
Johnny Bananas callbacks.
If I were you,
I wouldn't wait around
for a third.
[ Laughter ]
Can't be done.
Trump's screed calling
for the termination
of the Constitution came
[ Laughing ] after Twitter --
after Twitter CEO Elon Musk
released a big dud
he called the Twitter Files,
which was supposed
to be some kind of
Hunter Biden smoking gun,
but, in reality,
was just a bunch
of internal Twitter emails
about content moderation.
-Trump's cries to terminate
the Constitution came
after Elon Musk promoted a new
release of the Twitter Files --
internal emails showing
how the Trump White House
and the Biden campaign requested
and received removals
from certain content
on social media.
The former journalist
who compiled those notes
for Musk claimed,
"One executive would write
to another:
'More to review
from the Biden team.'
The reply would come back:
'Handled.'"
But reviews
of Internet Archive show
those links were explicit
pornographic images stolen
from Hunter Biden's
laptop hard drive,
not requests
from the Biden campaign
to suppress The New York Post
story itself.
-Yes, Trump wants
the Constitution terminated
because Joe Biden's campaign,
which was not the government
in 2020,
asked Twitter to take down pics
of Hunter Biden's dong.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry, but I don't think
there's a provision for that
in the Constitution.
I don't remember
Alexander Hamilton
ever writing, in the
Federalist Papers, that,
"The Constitution shall be
the law of the land,
unless John Adams' son posts
a lithographed flyer
of his genitals
in Faneuil Hall."
[ Laughter ]
Interesting historical fact --
John Adams son John Quincy Adams
was also president,
but later in life,
they had a falling out,
so, John Quincy Adams had
his name legally changed to...
-Johnny Bananas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There we go.
[ Cheering ]
And I am certain
that's the end of that.
[ Laughter ]
These guys are desperate to find
secret evidence
of a hidden conspiracy in the
laptop of the president's son.
Meanwhile,
Trump's out there admitting
he stole classified documents
from the White House
and they're all like, "So what?
We all still stuff from work."
What is it about the words
Hunter Biden's laptop
that drives right-wingers
absolutely insane?
It's all they can think about.
It's like that torture device
they make Bix wear in "Andor."
They just hear those three words
and they lose their minds.
Also, side note --
"Andor" rules!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Flat-out rules!
[ Laughter ]
And I'm not one of those people
who loves everything
about "Star Wars."
I'm an adult!
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
At some point,
you get too old for movies
where everyone has a crazy name,
like Kylo Ren or Poe Dameron
or...
-Johnny Bananas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Although,
I do get chills --
I do get chills every time
I remember
that famous line, "Help me..."
-Johnny Bananas.
-"...you're my only hope."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway.
The point is the rule of five
is an effective comedy device
[ Laughter ]
and also, even after the GOP
was repudiated in the midterms,
they're still leaning
even further
in the direction
of MAGA extremism.
For example,
right before he called
for the termination
of the Constitution,
Trump also recorded
a video message in support --
in support -- of the January 6th
insurrectionists,
even after the leader of the
Oath Keepers, Stewart Rhodes,
was convicted
of seditious conspiracy.
-Patriot freedom
is what it's about
and that's not happening
in our country.
What they've done
to torment people
and go after people
like never before,
I don't think anything like this
has ever happened
in our country before,
certainly not to this extent.
So, it's a very
unfair situation
and we're going to be,
as you know,
looking about it
and talking about it
very, very strongly
in the coming weeks, months,
and over the next period
of a year, year and a half,
during the campaign.
People have been treated
unconstitutionally,
in my opinion,
and very, very unfairly
and we're going to get
to the bottom of it.
-Content aside,
why is he standing so far away?
[ Laughter ]
Is he recording this
on a Mar-A-Lago security camera?
[ Laughter ]
Is he shrinking?
I don't know.
But that is exactly the kind
of rumor Donald Trump
would spread about that video
of Donald Trump.
[ As Trump ]
Have you seen that video
of Donald Trump?
They're saying he shrunk.
He's tiny now.
They're calling him Tiny Trump.
[ Laughter ]
Many people are saying
it's so sad he's 3'0", 2'0",
perhaps even 1'0" tall.
[ Laughter ]
He reminds me a lot
of Hermey the Elf.
[ Laughter ]
Great elf, tough elf.
I met him once.
He came up to me,
tears pouring down his face
and then freezing
to the side of his cheek
and he said to me, "Sir,
I just want to be a dentist."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, I've notice that Trump has
a new move with his hands.
They're like,
instead of doing up here,
he's started doing them
like down here.
[ Laughter ]
I guess that's why they had
to move the camera back.
He said --
[ As Trump ]
I do my hands down here now.
[ Laughter ]
And they said,
"Alright, but they're going
to be out of frame."
And he was like --
[ As Trump ]
Well, then you got to back
the camera up!
[ Laughter ]
The hands are up, people know
I'm not [bleep] crazy.
[ Laughter ]
With the hands --
With the hands, I look smart.
Without them, I look like I'm...
-Sue Smith.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Didn't see that one coming,
did you?
[ Laughter and applause ]
When you think I'm going to zig,
I zag!
[ Laughter ]
That's why they call me...
-Johnny Bananas.
-Yep.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Six.
[ Cheering ]
And, yet, even after all that,
Republicans still can't seem
to bring themselves
to oust Trump from their party.
Yesterday, George Stephanopoulos
asked GOP Congressman Dave Joyce
about Trump's call to terminate
the Constitution
and Joyce still said
he would support Trump
for president in 2024.
-Can you support a candidate
in 2024
who's for suspending
the Constitution?
-Well, again, it's early.
I think there's going to be
a lot of people in the primary.
I think, at the end of the day,
you'll --
whoever the Republican
then to pick,
I'll fall in behind
because that's --
-Even if it's Donald Trump
and he's called for suspending
the Constitution?
-Well, again, I think it's going
to be a big field.
I don't think Donald Trump's
going to clear out the field
like he did in '16.
-That's not what I'm asking.
I'm asking, if he's the nominee,
will you support him?
-I will support whoever
the Republican nominee is.
-That's a remarkable statement.
You'd support a candidate
who's come out for suspending
the Constitution?
-Well, you know,
he says a lot of things.
-But that's
an extraordinary statement.
You can't come out
against someone
who's for suspending
the Constitution?
-Well, first off,
he has no ability
to suspend the Constitution.
Secondly --
-But he says he's for it.
-Well, you know,
he says a lot of things that --
[ Laughter ]
But that doesn't mean that it's
ever going to happen.
-Well, that's reassuring.
[ Laughter ]
Trump wants to terminate
the Constitution,
but he can't,
so, don't worry about it.
It's kind of like how,
in every Bond movie,
M explains the villain's plans
to blow up the UN
and Bond says, "I'm sorry,
you mean this Austrian dork?
I doubt he's
blowing up anything,
unless it's in a game
of Minecraft."
[ Laughter ]
You'd think calling
for the termination
of the Constitution
would finally be the last straw,
but there will never be
a last straw for Republicans.
No matter how many times voters
repudiate Trump's extremism,
Republicans can't seem
to pry themselves away.
They're just hoping
someone else runs against him,
so, instead of getting asked,
"If he's the nominee,
will you support Donald Trump?"
They'll get asked...
-If he's the nominee,
will you support...
-Johnny Bananas.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-I don't know.
I don't know, Sal.
At some point,
you just can't call it back
that many times.
[ Laughter ]
Just like you got --
It's moderation, Sal.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]